republicans have been notably mixed in
their response to the president's
rhetoric and we've got ben tracy at the
white house for us following it all ben
good morning to you
what are you hearing from inside the
administration
good morning i'm told by sources here at
the white house that president trump has
no plans to concede even if joe biden
claims victory after being declared the
projected winner
now president trump did seem noticeably
dejected last night when he gave those
remarks here at the white house
and some republicans are heavily
criticizing his attacks on voting
and democracy itself maryland governor
larry hogan tweeted
there is no defense for the president's
comments tonight undermining our
democratic process
but others like senator lindsey graham
repeated the president's baseless claims
of fraud
and said he's donating five hundred
thousand dollars to the president's
defense team
now the trump campaign still does not
have any sort of coherent legal strategy
or even someone to lead it and cbs news
has learned that the president's
son-in-law and senior adviser jared
kushner
is trying to find somebody to fill that
role he's considering jay sekulow one of
the president's personal attorneys
who also helped defend him during the
impeachment trial
gail all right ben thank you very much